there is a story out of los angeles that
i did not believe was real
i thought this clearly this is either
the babylon b or this is some
sensationalist headline it's not real
here's what the headlines said said
that a 26 year old male child molester
was going to be sentenced
to
two years imprisonment
in a female
juvenile detention center
because of la's far left
d.a the prosecutor there george gascon i
said that's not possible hold on what
are you you're telling me that a guy is
a child molester
this guy molested little girls
and so to punish him
you're going to send him to a facility
full of little girls
that sounds like you're rewarding him
that sounds like you're sending him to
disney world
that's
how is that
how is that just how is that legal how
is that punishment
that's sick but this is a real story
james tubbs
when he was two weeks shy of his 18th
birthday
grabbed a girl by the neck
dragged her into a bathroom stall
you can use your imagination there's
evidence that he molested two other
little girls
he was finally connected with this case
years later
but la's far left george soros funded
district attorney george gascon
refused to try him as an adult
because when he committed the crime
years ago he was two weeks shy of his
18th birthday so this 26 year old
degenerate pervert
is being tried
as a minor
okay after he gets arrested
this guy's trying to figure out how he
can get out of punishment
so he decides because we are living in
clown world right now he decides he's
going to start identifying as a woman
only this doesn't happen before he gets
arrested by the way it's only after he
gets raised he says okay i'm hannah now
call me hannah
so james tubbs says okay i am
identifying as a girl
as a woman
and the district attorney is going to
identify me as a child so i
an
an old not old he's a young man but he's
a man he's an adult man i an adult man
i'm going to be identified as a little
girl and so i'm not gonna go to prison
for a really long time not gonna go to
prison at all i'm gonna go to
a juvenile detention facility
with a bunch of little girls
and here's the kicker this is the this
is the cherry on on top of this clown
sunday
the assistant district attorney john
hatami in los angeles
disagrees with the
d.a george gascon's decision here to
to
try james tubbs as a minor he says tubbs
is 26 years old unlike george gascon's
false narrative she is not a kid
she is not a kid she is not a she she's
a he
buddy are you kidding me
you're willing to go this far and say
hey the 26 year old's not really a 17
year old yeah the the chick isn't a
chick pal
the chick is a dude
frankly that's even crazier than a 26
year old being treated like a 17 year
old i think it's crazier to treat a male
child molester like a woman
james tubbs obviously
should be castrated and imprisoned for
life
minimum
minimum
this would that that perspective would
not have been controversial even 20
years ago
now that's shocking michael you're being
so provocative oh here comes the right
wing crazy you believe that
grown male child molesters shouldn't get
to live with little girls for two years
you believe that that child molesters
shouldn't be castrated and sent to
prison at the minimum this guy should be
castrated and imprisoned for life
frankly the same goes for george gascon
okay because this james tubbs is
obviously a pervert he's obviously a
degenerate and a pervert who needs very
severe punishment to possibly
one for the demands of justice but two
to hopefully in any way rehabilitate him
reform him
same goes for for the d.a
the d.a seems like a bigger pervert than
james tubbs in some ways because the d.a
is supposed to know better he's he's in
charge of public authority
this james tubbs is one sick puppy
george gascon is supposed to be in his
right mind and yet he's the one
indulging this and encouraging this sort
of thing
even the good guy in this story is
peddling delusion
and you know what
this is the natural conclusion
of the myths of our age this is the
natural conclusion of two delusions that
we are living under right now
one of them is the over-incarceration
delusion the other one is the
transgender delusion
the one delusion says we've got too many
people in prison in america
never mind that crime's going through
the roof we've got too many people to
pro we need to let criminals out of
prison
okay if you believe that then you're
going to do everything you can to not
send people to prison including trying
people who are adults
as juveniles where that's plausible
including giving people way lighter
sentences
instead of imprisoning this guy for
decades now just a couple years in a
little girl's facility and
transgenderism
because
if if this guy says that he's a woman
then he really is a woman according to
that delusion and so you have to put him
in a girls facility
so he's got to go to the women's
facility and because we it's a mass
incarceration we got to put him in the
juvenile facility
and as a result of those two
allegedly compassionate delusions we're
living under
some disgusting degenerate pervert 26
year old child molester is going to live
with little girls
something has gone seriously wrong in a
country that believes that
and i i have i have less sympathy for
the d.a
than i have for the for the
criminal himself
ring my bell ll ring my
bell right there ring it subscribe get
notifications even though sometimes
our friends here at youtube don't send
those notifications even when you do
subscribe which is why you got to go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts
subscribe
to the michael knowles show maybe leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]